I catch a boy Psychopaths or plants
they're wild blue no that's cool I was
beginning to think you turned all cold
[ __ ] on us honey sunshine and that's
not good yeah okay I guess we're just
gonna get a repaint all right [ __ ] sorry
yeah
yeah
hey oh okay I guess we're doing my name
is Cyrus Heppell Pierce think we have a
problem
Sean has been taken I was on the phone
with her when I heard a struggle and
someone else picked up her phone no her
virginity was taken that's what happened
oh let me take this present Oh only two
season here okay so when are you guys
gonna get in or oh okay I feel good and
it was a vaccine here okay
[ __ ] I always made a cut through the
heart mind never do
the SAG took her
the static is that like a a mythical
creature
what's going on here that's [ __ ] while
we're going all way down here
GPS getting crazy not you never know ah
[ __ ] I must rest up getting with things
fast
man it changes gears a dirty seconds
yeah we go we're finally flying now
yeah that seems faster why this is him
slow oh wait [ __ ]
Haddie is nitrous ago
there yeah
you see that that's because
Chay's it how far what is this place now
here we go this is the worst idea you've
ever had
we can't go marching on to snag the
aircraft carrier okay I look just like
Cyprus all I gotta add is a [ __ ]
attitude what happens when you're on
board I walk in with my prisoners they
take me to the cell block I grab chandi
and we leave I'm sorry
prisoners yeah hello Pierce oh yeah it's
not like doing [ __ ]
we're flying in let's plan let's grab a
snack transport soldiers this is
weirding me out okay so we get to the
carrier what then
prisoners are in the Brig right yeah you
bolt there we find Shaundi then I order
a prisoner transfer back here what if
they just shoot us
well that would ruin the plan wouldn't
it
oh [ __ ] this space looked like I can
pass for a self-righteous prick
considering I want to stab your ass
right now yeah I'd say it works that's
right say it works sir just slap that
face right off that's a month in the
hole for you
this isn't giving me any confidence oh
[ __ ] I Lowe's hit someone you sure you
got his face right I wants to count
around 20 pounds yeah I'm sure I'm just
saying piers this will work trust me
Saul I want it [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] I hit someone
find a VTOL okay
here we go here we go I'm here for the
VTOL the VTOL meaning [ __ ] we have a tip
bro
yeah there's a lot of [ __ ] B by the
air I shat and shaking my ass I'll
tickle making my [ __ ] [ __ ] tango
you know I said okay
okay Oh veto well so dope this is so
cool I cannot dance come on
this is a good look for you you should
keep the face when you're done with it
are you serious
Cyrus is very powerful in statuesque
costume just a suggestion don't get all
bent out of shape
that's going on here
uh-huh
huh
yeah I like that what's up Hank ups on
quick before we land
this is a horrible idea just do it
already look you may be cool with
wearing handcuffs but this [ __ ]
ain't down with that what's that
supposed to mean well you know you ran a
prostitution ring so clearly I'm into
key you carry a gun does that mean you
like to be shot No
so how about mental manchild okay
I'm a [ __ ] [ __ ] on there that's all I
gotta say
Oh welcome back sir
what's up I need you to sign off on some
prototypes I've been working on thanks
for the offer you but process these to a
sample I can take these two down to
detention for you sir thanks commander
this way sir
oh of course it's this way oh yeah yeah
this place is [ __ ] the ish good how
was your flight in the prisoners give
you any trouble no no it's uh it was
easy look sir
things don't have to be awkward between
us oh yeah we're both adults what
happened happened
and speaking for myself I don't regret a
thing I like men Oh what holy [ __ ]
sir R&D is sent a prototype for a new
vehicle a jet-propelled cycle they can
do that sir well I'm sure our DS had
some news before this one of them no sir
it is top quality good know about they
have some improvements to our okay good
she's miss something Josh and there's
also portable satchel charges for the
troops once we get to our D on the you
to sign up on two projects have you been
that's so slow and if you walk ahead
look lovely I'm like only afro hands
like [ __ ] gone now ii said okay okay
that's good
okay
okay so that's your name chef show us a
soccer boat yeah [ __ ] looks like one
have to pop a lot of [ __ ] shooting
she says okay okay
take this there find a break
I get that maybe harvest [ __ ] I get
in here
yeah yes I can
oh yeah how this past alive
okay there we go
[ __ ] oh all right accurate but I guess
that guy's got here
we copy over they'll Brigadier
is shouting right okay okay okay I
cleared this heavy dose thank ya Oh
and it's kind of thick not strong you
wanna make the pistols Oh sad a buck is
sure
[ __ ] did I just say miss Pierce okay
okay
yeah yes wait way yeah reactor control
room heard the guards talking about how
dangerous it was oh yeah
kans do this do this how getting some
real action you know none of that like
Jose boys shy you know yeah yeah yeah
we're like the Bruce and Fresno Brits in
here
anyways [ __ ] a oh my God my [ __ ]
getting tough step
what is this Oh destroy the console area
now what the [ __ ] out of here
trying to get down there's so much
spreading the goodness I love scripted
events yeah oh [ __ ] my [ __ ] it's got
[ __ ] sick inside but I blast okay I
always got time to snap up yeah
this is a spy there's a spy oh sure okay
take this help [ __ ] I guess I can't take
that one that's a piece of [ __ ] that's a
piece of [ __ ] I'll take the VTL baby
come on
this one's going in the for me we might
have overdone it now we can focus on
Kilbane what about stag we just blew up
an aircraft carrier what else could he
throw at us
you know become to martial law he'll
fall in line they all will of course
ma'am sir the commandos are enroute
we'll have the whole city locked down in
72 hours
outstanding Thank You Kia permission to
speak freely it's about damn time we
took off the kid gloves little words
shock okay it's got
tips out for Harambee